the Hermitage is the pride of st.
Petersburg it boasts one of the world's
best our collections millions of
tourists visit the Regal gallery every
year but right now alongside the
galleries collection of the great
masters visitors can check out a
painting by a giant of Contemporary Art
Gahan lichte plus there's Catalina
Felicia's sculpture made of seashells
Thomas here Shaun's installation is sure
to cause a stir designed to look as
though he's ripped a hole in the side of
the museum the works are all part of
Manifesta curators have defended the
decision to organize the Contemporary
Art Show and Russia amid political
tensions by the image of Hermitage once
the Winter Palace is one of the wonders
of the world so it's the chance of a
lifetime you'd be mad not to take it and
the artists were quite keen for it to go
ahead MOS technology and true to
tradition the exhibition confronts the
big taboos of Vladimir Putin's Russia on
display or marlene dumas portraits of
gay men and pictures from ukrainian
photographer Boris Mikhailov which
document Kiev's Maidan revolution
McAuliffe says he couldn't understand
the calls for artists to boycott the
show in Russia yay attention if you have
something to say then you should say we
had to take part here it would have been
different if they'd stopped us from
expressing our views that's cuz I so
it's full steam ahead for Manifesta
despite months of controversy over its
staging here